Australians may have to get used to
scenes like this dozens of wildfires
breaking out as the country has declared
a rare combination of two climate events
threatening months of extreme heat and
dry weather we're always planning for
Bush and grass fires here in in
Southeastern Australia particularly here
in New South Wales it is something that
we live with every year and we need to
be prepared for it but ultimately this
year does look a little bit more
challenging than we've seen for several
years
in and around Sydney the official fire
danger rating is Extreme but has hit the
highest level of catastrophic this week
the risk has prompted a total fire ban
and some schools have been closed
here at the rural Fire Service
headquarters they are planning for the
worst while hoping for the best warning
people to be aware of the dangers two
rare climate events a positive Indian
Ocean bipole and the better known El
Nino have come together and the effects
will be felt globally not just here in
Australia
Indonesia's Capital Jakarta has been
choking on toxic air caused by forest
fires there and drought as devastated
farming in the Philippines and Thailand
Australia has already assisted Canada in
its fight against record wildfires this
year
there's only so much that agencies can
do there's only so much government can
do we need the community to do their bit
people need to prepare their own
properties they need to prepare
themselves they need to have discussions
with their family about what they'll do
when fire threatens and that's the same
no matter where you go in the world with
global leaders scientists and activists
meeting at the un's climate action
Summit in New York the problem is stuck
Alex Thomas Al Jazeera Sydney
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera